These are things that make men instantly more hot.
Starting off with No.
1 when they're unaware of how attractive they are.
When men are oblivious to how attractive they are,
it's just an instant panty dropper.
Men who are aware of this are kind of the worst.
Number two when a man has five o'clock shadow.
Okay, this is a personal preference,
but it gets me every time.
Number three when he has a low voice.
Not like a very white voice,
but a nice low voice.
Makes someone's less attractive qualities way more attractive.
Developed a crush on voices alone.
No. 4 the ability to have banter.
There's nothing worse than having witty banter with a brick wall
that actually makes guys less attractive.
Smelling like a man.
And not necessarily anything that sold out of a bottle,
just light pheromones. That scent is so damn appealing to any woman.